según irán eeuu se encuentra solo de
manera unilateral washington dio por
restablecidas las sanciones de la onu
contra teherán que habían sido retiradas
tras el acuerdo nuclear de 2015 pero el
consejo de seguridad desestimó tales
medidas algo que el gobierno iraní
celebra como una victoria
no me son musulmanas
el mundo de la diplomacia ha sido
testigo de tres derrotas consecutivas de
los estadounidenses en el consejo de
seguridad de la onu
[Música]
de enero
de acuerdo con las partes europeas eeuu
no puede aplicar tales sanciones porque
ya no pertenece al acuerdo nuclear que
decidió abandonar en mayo de 2018 pero
washington prometió castigar a quienes
se opongan a su voluntad la situación
parece no inquietar a los iraníes
es realmente difícil para el pueblo
iraní en este momento ya sea que se
vuelvan a imponer estas sanciones o no
no obstante estamos viviendo con grandes
dificultades no hace ninguna diferencia
para nosotros
irán ya vive una situación difícil tras
retirarse del acuerdo nuclear eeuu re
impuso sus propias sanciones a la
república islámica lo que ha golpeado
duramente su economía
no sigo las noticias y en particular
este caso porque hemos pasado por cosas
difíciles y aún están en curso después
de todo no hay nada peor que lo peor
la caída en los precios del petróleo y
una pérdida de hasta el 75 por ciento
del valor de la moneda local son el
mayor desafío nuevas sanciones solo
complicarían aún más la situación en el
país más afectado por el cob y 19 en
medio oriente